and now
i thought this would be an interesting
thing to show so bill maher and you guys
know i've been somewhat critical of bill
maher because he's he's just late to the
party and and it's fine and when you're
late to the party
i think those of us that have been here
first that have gotten most of this
stuff right we want to be gracious to
the people that get here but we also
want to get them to the end of the road
well bill maher on his show on real time
this past friday
really went off on justin trudeau and i
would just preface this by saying bill
maher a liberal and justin trudeau the
head of the liberal
party
in canada
take a look he started to read what he
he said this is a couple of weeks ago he
was or maybe this is september but he
was talking about people who are not
vaccinated
he said they don't believe in science
they're often misogynistic often racist
no they're not that was not part of him
at all right he said but they take up
space
and with that we have to make a choice
in terms of a leader as a country do we
tolerate these people it's like tolerate
dude now you do sound like that's that
way and recently he talked about them
holding holding unacceptable
views i'm surprised to hear that trudeau
said those things
you didn't see the black face i mean
no i'm kidding
i'm not
i mean that was not a good look for him
i i mean
come on i mean that's i think what gets
under people's skin
all right putting aside bill maher for
just a moment there's marianne
williamson on there marian wilson who
has had i've had on the show
uh who did my show and then the second
the cameras went off basically told me
that she actually was a libertarian and
that she had never got as much hate from
the right as she was getting from the
left and she called it a cult
not only is that true i assure you that
that's true but she was also i think it
was on eric bowling's show on newsmax
once where they left the mic on after if
i'm not mistaken and she said the exact
same thing to him but so she sits there
shocked she's got her duck face you know
she does a
that thing that women do
like just
i'm shocked i can't believe they trudeau
would say that sort of i can't believe
it but she's a good liberal too why are
you shocked this is what you people have
brought upon us so first again i want to
give bill maher total credit here and
watching him get there has been great
and again bill you gotta and i know the
producers are watching you gotta get to
the end of the road you gotta tell
people to stop voting for democrats it's
as simple as that otherwise you guys
just usher in all of the nonsense and
then you try to basically destroy
republicans and conservatives and then
two years later you just repeat what
they're saying and then everybody
applauds you for it this game cannot be
played anymore like maybe there was a
time where that game could be played
right and i get it like the real-time
show is sort of an airlock for what's
allowed in in mainstream culture or
something like that but this cannot be
played anymore you get it bill so it's
time you can't just say uh the liberals
the liberals your royal idiot i'm a good
liberal no maybe there's something wrong
maybe there's some a bigger problem okay
i don't want to get lost on that
but it's good to see it by and large it
is good to see that this is happening